bending and everybody including the
players is a lot closer to that amazing
trophy look at it it's so beautiful is
that real gold it might be your arts
limited doing an amazing job with that I
cannot believe how beautiful it is
you guys better give them the lights
it's not even fair if you don't give
them a lot I'm just saying it's right
there it's on the stage and that's what
our grand champion will be receiving
here ladies and gentlemen and it could
be possibly one of these two people you
see in front of you especially after
that match we just saw Anna can play
with hope this is gonna be the loser
semi-finals
we've got radiance Red Bull Anakin going
up against fate Olsen first to two games
and somebody is definitely going home
but guys you know what time it is if you
guys would like faith old sod to take it
and go on in this bracket make some
noise out there I know what this means
oh yeah I know what this means if you
guys would like anakin to take it and
move on make some noise out there and
here we go Jack versus Kazumi constantly
alright are when you go onto the wall
don't cheer for me yo chicken feet Tiger
tipping is dead now while standing for
damage definitely on the side of ulsan
already great combo starting off and
carry his will back to the middle no man
just one step ahead a lot of these
instances the balcony already broken in
the first round you just want more space
just want more space to work with here
and we see those don't go to infinite
age before they get there just prefer
the infant stage more space to better Oh
double wanted to do it again the old son
has been phenomenal today Oh everything
is hitting right now literally
everything use attempt he's working out
finally end with some deep end catches
them alright to stick around looking a
little better also I'm still with a
slight lightly though
small sauce don't fish it earlier and
this is how you know we suck double cats
him a little bit earlier do these lifts
and about range too lots of space of a
play right now but look how close they a
wall is the whole science bag so many of
them anybody looking ready for the low
pay on the get up kick and that should
be the round and the wall first two
rounds here in game number one told you
man a lot of people sleeping on old time
and we saw up in that group play and I
was like oh man that guy is a definitely
still ridiculous and look at this Jack
handle that way and here crowd still
rallying behind them more jackhammer
pressure now for managing the bat twos
gonna connect on a trade this time Oh
pressure robot love tonight those poor
threes for the win points that Bulls
that I've been doing all day I've been
just phenomenally plays look at the
carry he got off their first game for
old so that's three rounds straight it's
just small things right there like that
last little interaction right there I
felt like was so important from stopping
Anakin from getting that momentum back
yeah this is so dominant of a first game
there for Ulsan the first round or two
everything he tried was working out
there and it can go right back into it
with the rematch let's see if you can
get it done here row same strategy he
was against no me at four to lunch we've
seen also I knew that now for one two
and let it rip is not safe he's been
getting punished consecutively but still
going to and all son tried that delayed
hockey saw no be had some success if it
doesn't find it Oh rocket kick was it I
don't know funky combo but old son now a
gentleman was working on it perfect just
a second ago but also now gonna be so
dangerous and no down back to I'm gonna
close on the round can't get on the
board it's last they've had me a little
worried right there but also I'm taking
a first game one round on the side
okay start going back to those folks to
control the range yeah definitely add it
up he's like you like using those loans
you like tapping the ankles I can do it
too
Wow drop it on Perry so clutch we know
the Anakin loves to go for the ankle see
my loves to open people up starting with
that low off and but now getting a
little Perry costing around old no
slouch looking just in and out these one
two for the pressure you know Jack's not
real stepping right so easy to choose
that running keep a pressure chemical
and it's so much harder right cousin cos
only does a great job of blocking it
down and making sure you don't have
access to like those tools to keep her
out right and let them get opportunity
to try the jackhammer just so you get
the while setting punch and just like
that
set point for fake holes on going to the
top three right now Annika needs to make
something big happen right now starts it
off with it down for one intercepted
with a jab from ole sign the neck resume
we also have a pretty good job with silk
behind Italy finding a hit with that
down for one - no we haven't done just
pushing antic until the wall right now
no wall combos good Braddock in here but
he's way behind now before one to stop
the move it does another punish
fishing with that magic for Anika says
no but it the shoot a minute
low block from a deacon deepak be glad
that devious blow chant and conduct that
raise now though it should have been
over thought should've been able to
close out with a key now still has a
chance old son with rage
candy still closing out here it's bill
setpoint forty seconds left on the clock
the downer gonna go for place old
sucking it back to the losers final guys
please please this is a dear friend of
mine make some noise for radiance red
bull and it can put in amazing year one
of the people to hell to to his work
look how far he has come representing
the USA and more importantly
representing the egg oh my goodness what
a separate old sod you know he has been
so darn good here today through the
group stages now through the loser
bracket I said it earlier I don't feel
like he really lost in that group stage
I don't really don't feel like a lot and
he's just showing that through every
single said he's happier you know Anton
had a couple of chances there at the end
but just fell a little bit short of
bringing it back together theater well
look we've been talking about all sign
all day so let's take a quick look at
the bracket